Washington DC's traffic cam police squad
recently slapped local celebrity chef G
off Tracy with over 400 dollars in fines
the crime violation of the posted
breakneck 25 mile an hour speed limit of
a double lane down hill stretch of Fox
after admitting his guilt and paying off
his tickets in a timely fashion
chef G off hired a sign spinner to stand
by the road warn oncoming drivers of the
pending speed trap that's right
this once seemingly affable gentlemen
uber successful entrepreneur and pillar
of the community has turned into a
rabble rouser oh the worst kind the type
of citizen activist who wants to prevent
you and others from suffering a hefty
arbitrary traffic fine at the hands of
the money-grubbing DC government in
other words structure must be stopped
here are the facts Washington DC's
traffic cameras raked in over 43 million
dollars in 2010 and now is not the time
to threaten such reliable cash now the
city's currently facing a dire budgetary
surplus and DC government officials need
these revenues for youth sports programs
and other completely ethical purposes
that absolutely never involve despotism
of financing personal expenses of argot
those camera boxes are more than just
ice tours folks very central to
increasing traffic congestion throughout
the city
besides the district needs a reliable
way to discourage outsiders from
patronizing local businesses and
visiting our historic city without speed
cams acting is effective deterrent to
travel and commerce the DC government
might be forced to raise its already
obnoxiously inflated hotel restaurant
parking garage taxes call chef job and
tell him to stop hiring sign spinners to
warn drivers about the location or the
district sneakiest the most egregious
speed traps
better yet stop by one of his four
community located restaurants and tell
him personally just don't buy any of his
scrumptious culinary delights after all
you would want to support a guy who's
trying to look out for the best interest
of his chameleons his own expense
especially since he's renowned for
producing fine contemporary American
cuisine with the casual sophistication
and
hospitality we need less of that chef
Jia you just can't trust a guy who
spells his name off funny like that
you